well it's good to be here I'm pleased to
see that as soon as anyone puts up a
chat at a conference people try and hack
it with cross-site scripting it's a good
good sign for a tech conference I'm Alex
macaw and actually we're already off to
a good start because in my last
presentation that J's Kampf
I actually spelled my name wrong so
they're already off to a good start
so this the this slides about the
deconstruction of a JavaScript web app
and this JavaScript web app is called
monocle now I can't want to give you a
warning that this presentation is really
code heavy but pretty pretty much every
slide has code on it and we're going to
try and cover the whole out which also
means Ruby and CoffeeScript so a little
warning there so what is monocle well
it's the social news aggregation side
it's a lot like hacking use if you use
that and you can go and check it out
monocle dot IO and it's got a very
pretty in a face done by a designer
friend of mine and we have posted on the
Left content on the right and members
can post new links and post comments and
they're just we're extracting a bit of
the post a bit of text from the post and
we're also extracting a preview image so
today I'm open sourcing this see if you
actually go to github.com slash macman
slash monocle you can download it and I
actually suggest you clone it right now
so you can actually go through the code
as I'm talking about it it'll give you a
lot more context to the app so I'm just
gonna give you a few moments to do that
if you open it up you'll see the
structure structure and you'll notice
that it's using Sinatra the whole app is
built on Sinatra and most of the
application code is under the app
directory so notice we also have this
MVC architecture we have models views
controllers in this case we call
controllers routes now any client-side
code is on their app assets and the
father bootstraps the whole app is
called AB dot RB makes sense right this
is what it looks like
notice we're adding each route as
middleware each route is its own Sinatra
app which is I think the best way of
actually architecting Sinatra apps so we
are adding rec deflator therefore
gzipping support we are adding RAC CSRF
there for cross-site scripting
cross-site request forgery attack
prevention and then we're adding our own
routes so we have static first not just
static files we have the users for users
API we have the route the posts are out
for the posts API comments for comments
API and the client and the last one is
actually what serves up our JavaScript
client so let's mosey down into the
client and have a look at that if you
open up client dot RB you can see our
client is bootstrapped in a few steps
first any request to / or / posts is
caught now this rather ugly regex is
what's doing that there's a there's
actually a better way of doing this but
for now we're using a regex so our
JavaScript client will be served up at
any of those URLs so regardless of if
they're for a force so we didn't
actually check to see if a URL is rather
at this point we also check to see if
the request is from supported mobile
client and if it is then we serve up a
specialized mobile version of the app so
let's took take a look at index dot our
er B which is being rendered there this
is what it looks like we have one
concatenated CSS file one concatenated
javascript file
we have nothing in the body tag and
everything is generated and notice how
we have defer and all the script tags
that makes sure that the page isn't
blocked during rendering and also notice
that we have the setup to J's file which
is actually going to bootstrap the app
it's going to accentuate the app with
pre-loaded data so we jump back to
client client dot RB we can actually see
how these assets are generated anything
under slash assets is being served up by
sprockets
which is a Ruby asset manager I use it
everywhere I highly recommend you use it
and the thing underst
it set up the gist is generated by that
little function there it actually
generates this JavaScript file and it
pre-populated with data you can see
we're doing a sequel query here we're
setting up some options instance
variable and then we're rendering the
setup DRB a template if we jump down
into that you can see that the EOB
generates some JavaScript and you can
see all it's doing is requiring the app
and I'll get on a bit later in the talk
about how require actually works and
then instantiating this app variable and
appending it to the body so if we go
through the steps again browser
navigates to slash the client which
matches this the client slash route
returns indexed or ARB whereas the
fetches CSS and JavaScript and then also
the setup that Jas and then the browser
is instantiated and then app is ready so
so we look at the front end which is
probably better topic for this
conference
it's an MVC structure - - we have
controllers we have models we have views
and in this case the views are eco
templates which is a CoffeeScript
templating framework or language
actually it's much easier to look at
these controllers visually we have one
main app controller which encompasses
the whole app everything else belongs to
that then we have two main sub
controllers
the sidebar this is Sabo doc modular
coffee and then we have hosts the post
controller posts top modular coffee and
then those two main sub controllers
themselves have self controllers we have
the post details and we also have post
comments now the key thing is to note
that none of these controllers know
about the other controllers they only
know about the sub controllers they only
know about models so although they're
all really decoupled if we're going to
talk about decoupling we can't not talk
about conscious modules so if you notice
all this files on the front-end have dot
module in the file name this is because
they're common jeaious modules now what
exactly does that mean well commonjs
gives you require and it gives you
exports and they're absolutely critical
to building I think any large JavaScript
apps without them you get spaghetti code
and you get a namespace pollution so if
you're using sprockets then you can
easily get a common chair support by
just adding the gem sprockets comment
yes there you just add that gem and
you're good to go all you have to do is
put module on the file name and we'll
wrap it up as a common Janus module and
essentially this means the file is
wrapped by some boiler pote boilerplate
code and so it's executed in a local
scope and that boilerplate code also
gives it the require function and the
ability to export values and functions
so you have required at the top you can
require the modules and then at the
bottom of every single module you have
an export which basically exposes
particular values so if you now go back
to index dot module dot RB a few things
should make more sense now this is the
main app controller if you remember
everything else belongs to that at the
top we're loading in all the controllers
and models we're going to need and then
we create this class code app this is
the Harriton from controller and
exporting at the bottom when app is
instantiated we're setting we're using
all the preloaded data passed him by
selectively Jas and then finally we
instantiate our main sub controllers
pending them to the page and then if you
have a look at post controller it's very
similar we're doing the same thing we're
acquiring our controllers we're
listening to events and we're appending
sub-controllers so it's fairly
straightforward now you may have noticed
this controller object they were
inheriting from what exactly is that
well if you've built MVC II apps before
you may be familiar with controllers the
C part of MVC a lot of MVC libraries
call these views like backbone I call
them controllers is just terminology now
in molecule I'm not actually using
backbone I'm not actually using spine
I'm using this pasteurization of both of
them which it combines what I think is
some of the best ideas from both for
them and I actually want to take you
through some of this library because I
think it's simple and has some neat
approaches that you can apply to your
own apps even if you're not using the
sly berry so this is controller dot
module dock coffee and this is found in
the vendor directory and this is the
whole library right here
so a controller's job is scoping
behavior to a single element so every
single controller has a single element
called e/l now there might be a little
hard to read it might be a bit small I'm
sorry about that but you can see at the
top we're creating this element and then
we're creating a jquery wrapped version
of this element which is called dollar
e-l and then a lot of controllers have
this class named property if that's
present we're adding it to the element
we're heading at class to the element
and what was it going to listen to this
removed event I'm going to talk more
about that later ignore it for now so
most of the controller functions are
just delegating straits to that jQuery
wrapped element and they're adding
events appending bits of HTML that kind
of thing
so the last two functions in this
controller file of view and template and
they make it really easy to to fetch an
eco template and render it and pass
through helpers to it so you can see
that sprockets creates this global
variable called jst and it hatches all
the templates to it as properties now
you can just fetch your template there
it'll be a function you look it up by
property it'll be function and then you
can execute that function pass through a
context and you'll get a string all view
is doing is actually decorating the
context with any helpers that are
present so in otherwise you render views
like this you pass a view a function
named sorry ever a template name it
returns a function itself and then I you
basically execute that function in you
pass your context so when it compiled
rendered as a string and then you just
set the elements HTML to that string
pretty straightforward
now let's talk about something pretty
neat let's jump back into the controller
library and talk about that removed
event now this removed event will
actually be fired whenever that
controller is removed from the DOM and
then our release function is called now
this is a pretty useful little utility
because if you've registered any global
event handlers say listening to keyboard
events for example in the controllers
constructor then in the release function
the bottom you can unregister those
events basically cleanup a global event
lessness other language like objective-c
have same kind of thing so how does that
removed event as you get fired
well we're kind of using this neat trick
called jquery a special events and you
can have a look this is basically the
entire codes to fire that removed event
and it's in jQuery dot event or remove
dot coffee
so whenever jquery removes an element it
actually passes it through this clean
data function jquery dot clean data
which actually goes through a removes
all the event listeners the jQuery is
added to that element and now this is
useful because in some browsers like IE
event listeners aren't removed properly
and you get memory leaks so jQuery has
to actually remove all the event
listeners from itself and you can just
tap into that functionality and define
your own event and the zone your own
events could removed and wait and when
jQuery tries to clean up this event from
elements you actually fire it rather
than clean it up and so then you
automatically fire this removed event
and then it'll trigger the release
function and controllers and you
automatically cleaning up controllers
and there's a very simple way of doing
that so we cover the controller library
let's jump back into the post controller
notice we've got the state objects now
which we're adding an event listener to
this post property now whenever I want
had to have global state in my app I
have to attach it to the state object
now I try to keep global state to a
minimum and and actually a monocle the
only property is in global state are the
current user the current environment
like developmental production and
crucially the currently viewed post
which is what we're listening to here so
whenever that changes the controller is
going to re-render itself if you have a
look at the state module state of
modular coffee it essentially looks like
this we have a state class that inherits
from model and and notice the bottom
that we're actually instantiating that
state class there's only ever one
instance of their state class so there
are other models too that represent all
the major data structures in the app we
have posts comments etc these are all
whole data related state rather than
view related state which is a realm of
the controller and if you have a look at
the post mod model post on wanted of
coffee it looks a bit like this however
I'm gonna stop right there because it's
unlikely you're going to be using this
custom MVC framework
there's got no following your support
it's just something I like tinkering
around with so I won't expand a much of
this part of app but what I do want to
cover is parts that you are gonna reuse
that it hopefully be useful in the kind
of JavaScript apps that you're making
such as scoping CSS so let's take a
simple controller this is the landing
page this is displayed if no post is
selected notice the top we have this
class name property pretty much every
controller has this when instantiated
this class name will be actually being
added to the controller's element every
controller has a corresponding CSS file
so posts landing dot module has this
post
unschooling dot CSS style CSS file now
I'm not actually using stylus sorry I'm
not actually using plain CSS I'm using
stylus for this if you're not familiar
stylus it's just another CSS
preprocessor like less or sass but the
key thing here is that notice that
everything in this CSS file is named
spaced by the class name property we
said earlier so all the CSS is specific
to that controller so my advice is to
make CSS as specific as possible when
you're making the large JavaScript apps
don't worry about China's too much
repetition will be removed a lot by
gzipping there may be a performance
impact for this but again you can
approach that later if if it's a problem
now if a controller has sub controllers
then you may find that a controller CSS
is actually affecting all those elements
that are appended to it and this just
means you need to get more specific you
can use the right-hand bracket here and
that's what only select the direct
children of this element I want to talk
a bit about how we created the
scrollable list and the side bar of
Monaco and also how we added keyboard
shortcuts to it if you use the up and
down arrow keys you'll notice that they
work right in Monaco you have this
infinite list a post in the sidebar
now this list is actually rendered by
the posts lists controller and each list
item is rendered by the posts item
controller it makes sense if we open up
the posts lists controller post list or
modular coffee we can step through the
execution flow and see what's going on
okay so the controller is instantiated
and we're calling render immediately
surrender just cleans up the dom
basically empties all the elements in
the controller and then cause a doll and
then a doll will iterate through this
collection the collection is basically
just an array of posts instances and
then for each one and we'll call this
add one function and that just append a
new post item to the controller's
element now the post item controller
will take care of rendering itself
rendering a little section of that list
and it'll take care of rear-ending it if
the name changes of the the vote the
upvote score increases that kind of
thing and it'll also take care of
listening to click events when people up
vary posts now if you remember earlier
we had this global state with a post
property so if we actually listen to
that we can actually light whichever
post is currently selected so we're
listening to the change post anyway we
can get rid of the little video the
bottom it's kind of blocking the code so
we're listening to the the posts
property on state and we're calling the
set post function whenever it changes
now if we define set post function what
we can do is we're setting this instance
variable called at post and then we're
calling set active instead active will
iterate through all the Dom elements in
the list
remove the active class and then if
there is a post it'll try and find that
using a data ID selector and add the
class of accident to it and then we've
got this interesting function scroll
into view if needed
and what exactly does that do well is
actually a little-known WebKit function
it's on elements inside WebKit and it
does what it says on the tin so in this
case of abstracted it - jQuery plug-in
but slightly just a method on Dom
elements and if you call it Atlas it'll
scroll that element into the view it's
super useful and in other browsers that
aren't WebKit based there and you can
just use this shim so this ensures that
whatever current element is selected
it'll be visible which is important when
you're doing up-and-down keyboard
navigation which is the next section so
we can add up and down
keyboard bindings to the sidebar
controller
so again if you open up side by top
modular coffee we can add a global event
listener for key down in the constructor
here and then we can clean that up in
the release function they remember
that's quite important because if the
controller's roof removed from the Dom
we want that to be cleaned up now we
actually have a key mapping property on
here now you can see that that's just
mapping a key code to a function name so
38 is the up key 40 down key we also
have this key down event listener
callback which is what we were listening
to it's listening to keyboard events in
the document so basically all it does is
check to see if there's a key mapping
for a specific event key code and if
there is it'll execute it so in this
case we have two callbacks 38 40 up and
down caret keys and the keyboard so down
arrow down a rate goes down key which in
turn calls next post notice that what
we're doing is looking to see which item
has an active class and then we're using
jQuery is next and dot previous
functions to try and find whatever the
next previous element is click on it and
we just basically simulate a click it
as if the user clicked it themselves but
we have a problem here we have a
scrolling conflict because the browser
also uses the up and down arrow keys to
scroll the contents so if you remember
we're actually managing the scrolling of
the sidebar ourselves were scrolling to
view if needed we could just cancel all
the scroll events but the scrolling that
needs to happen in other parts of the
app so these are actually the two main
scroll areas we have the sidebar we have
the main content so we basically need to
figure out which areas focus if the
sidebar has focus then we can just
cancel scroll events or and that are
associated with the up and down arrow
keys and do the scrolling ourselves if
it's if the main part number two has
focus then we need to not scroll the
sidebar and we just need to let the
browser as you scroll the content itself
so if you think about it the the active
areas with is whichever area was clicked
last so I try to find a browser API to
do this doesn't exist I tried for hours
you think it would exist it's kind of a
logical thing to put in the browser but
it doesn't so we're gonna have to do
this ourselves we can create this jQuery
door active area Coffee jQuery plugin
and all it does is you can mark up
active areas in your app and it will
listen to click events on them when a
click event is listed or activated it's
going to call this active area callback
and then it's just going to set the
current variable and then we can have
another function that just checks to see
if if specific Dom element is the
current one so let's mark up our active
areas and the posts and sidebar
controller
these are our two main areas that are
scrollable if you remember now these are
going to be listened to
now we go back to our sidebar controller
what we can do is check to see if the
element is active if it's not just
ignore the event it's that simple
I want to talk a bit about dynamic
pagination now this is a pretty tricky
problem actually so in molecule thus
order a post on the left side is
actually dynamic a single vote could
cause the post to raise up or down and
also there's a time decay which also
affects rankings but once the user is
scroll to the bottom of this list we
need to figure out what the next pages
fetch it and add it to the list we we
need to figure out the next page even if
it involves not putting duplicates in
this one even if the list has already
changed so what do other people do well
what does hacking use do well actually
stores every single possible sort
combination in enclosure and as you can
imagine this gets bigger and bigger is
exponentially huge as you have more
posts so what what happens ultimately
well the garbage collector kicks in and
and then it cleans up this closures and
that means you get expired pagination
link so you may have seen it in hacker
news it's kind of shitty really it kind
of does the same thing except it shows
even more duplicates on the second page
so how do you solve this well I was on
holiday would take Thornton recently and
he told me what he did with medium and
it's very simple but it's very good I
think hex to this problem so in other
words what you do is whenever you fetch
the next page of posts you send an array
containing all the previously fetched
post items IDs so the ones that you
already have on the page you send that
to the server then whenever you return
posts from the server you ensure that
those ideas are not referenced in the
from the resulting set so this is what
the Ruby code looks like you find the
popular posts you exclude any which have
an ID of the array that's passed in and
then you return them you limit it by 30
and routes you return the next page it
works great
that's the solution to that problem
real-time streaming while actually
monocle uses real-time streaming to keep
us interface up-to-date so if you up
vote a posts or add a new comment or add
a new post those things are gonna be
reflected instantly across everyone
viewing well how do we do this serve a
certain event now this is the easiest
form of real-time streaming I think on
the browser if you only need pub/sub and
you don't need bi-directional
communication use server-side events
they are so much simpler than WebSockets
they don't have a binary protocol it's
very simple in fact I can show you the
protocol right here in a ruby example so
all you have to do is make sure that
spot responses contain this content type
of text slash event stream then you need
to keep the connection open then to
write to a streams connection you just
write data code on and then the message
and then you line your line and that is
the entire protocol that's what
WebSockets should have beat but yeah we
had luckily we have server sent events
so back in the day I used to have this
project called juggernaut which as she
did real-time streaming every flash when
server-side events came along I call it
a day I was like
the browser has fixed this problem we
can deprecated Jagga no problem is
solved however what I realized is that
people want abstraction and I wanted
abstraction for monocle
so I made this thing called Sinatra -
pops up so gem anyone can use it and
it'll deal with channels and they'll
deal with cross-origin request headers
and I'll deal with keep our lives and
read as pub/sub and it's it's kind of
geared towards using it on Heroku
so here's another example of using this
library here we're publishing a talk
message to the tick channel and we have
a client subscribing to it so on the
client side you just use this event
source object and you just pass it
through a URL and then it will start
streaming from the server and this slash
subscribe route is actually what set up
by Sinatra pops up so that is all you
need to do to stream this talk message
claim and in fact if you go to J's can't
- ticked at her oh crap calm I set up
the simple example of this you know
it'll just stream these tick messages
it's pretty boring to be honest it
doesn't do much more than that so I'm
telling you all of this because Monica
has the streaming setup server under
stream Monica bio and if you look at the
stream module in vendor I've abstracted
event source a bit and I made it pass or
the event or the messages that it
actually gets so I made it pass through
Jason and then I'm firing my own event
on this stream module so if you have a
look on the server side notice that we
have this is an example of how a post is
voted we have this publish method right
here and this publish method basically
interacts with Sinatra pub/sub rise the
message to all channels in this case
we're publishing that a post got voted
upon and now if we have a look
and I client-side again it's just kind
of cut out you we can perform the
appropriate action we can listen to the
posts vote event and then we can in this
case what we're doing is we're just
refreshing that post we're fetching it
again from the server and we'll have the
updated book count so you in other ways
you can add this kind of real-time
streaming to your app very very simply
probably do only take you half now so
adding SEO to Monica was pretty easy
Google have this Ajax crawling
specification and basically all we need
to do is set up a robot friendly version
of the site's one that isn't rented with
JavaScript so if you go to this URL and
you include the underscore skate of the
score fragment under Scott exactly as
shown there you'll see the robots
friendly version of the site and it
looks a bit like this it's just a plain
HTML there's no JavaScript in there or
anything else now the key to making a
google fetch your page like this
is this metatag you just put it in your
main site and what Google do as soon as
it comes across this meta tag it all
read request the page again and they'll
add that underscore escape fragment
underscore to the URL what you can do on
the server side is just detect if that
is there and then you can render your
spider friendly page so you simply
implement a route that checks for it and
in fact in Sinatra you can do this in a
little nicer way what you can do is add
a route condition so this route or any
match if escape fragment is in the
parameters on the client side in in the
rendered ARB it looks a bit like this we
just have plain HTML we have an h1 tag
important for SEO we have a Meta
Description tag again important for SEO
that is what is displayed inside Google
search engine and then and then that's
it we have SEO if you go to a site
kernel monocle to i/o if you just google
that you'll see there's a bunch of
monocle has been indexed by Google it
works pretty well so I want to make sure
that the user doesn't quit the tab when
certain Ajax requests are in the fly
such as creating new posts voting that
kind of thing
so what we can do for this is use the
under for unload event which we can use
to warn the user they mean lose data if
they continue closing the tab now this
event is actually really a pseudo event
it's not really event can only have one
Handler and it's called just before the
page closes and now if a string is
returned from this event then that all
that string will be prompted to the
clients and then they had the option to
close the tab or not so that's the only
control you have for security reasons
now jQuery has this active property it's
an undocumented but it'll an active
property is basically in an integer
count of the current Ajax connections so
there's more than one connection and
then this flow control would turn true
a string will be returned the user be
prompted to see if they actually want to
close the tab now actually I found a bug
in Google Chrome where the cache gets
completely booked if you use on before
unload so the only way to actually walk
around this is set before I unload only
when the page isn't and then that
unnoted will state so if you have a look
at jQuery done close this is another
plugin than the vendor read directory
which I wrote from wanaka you can see
that if whenever there's an ajax request
being sent out we're incrementing our
own active transforms integer and then
we're adding the handler if there are
active transforms and then we're doing
the opposite when the HX request is
complete lastly I want to talk about the
wake event so we want to make sure that
the computer wakes up the browser
fetches the latest posts from Monika
because people keep tabs open for a long
time
we don't want data to get stale on there
but there's no browser API API for this
there is a browser API for page
visibility but actually doesn't help
here so we again we have to do it
ourselves
I've ridden this plugin again as she's
caught jquery waked up coffee nodejs
but what we can what it's doing here is
using timers to detect if we think
there's been a page sleep now since
timers executed a relatively predictable
interval we can check each iteration and
see if it matches at the current time is
is what we expect it to be if it isn't
the likelihood is that the computer
probably paused the timers during asleep
and then we can execute our awake event
now all we have to do in index don't
want to do the coffee is listen to this
wake event refresh the posts and we're
done I want to thank you very much for
listening to this talk and if you have
any questions we have it
all right thank you so much Alex now we
have a time for a few questions before
we go on a break
does anyone have any questions please
raise your hands
all right there's a gentleman here um so
I've just got once what go back quite a
bit into the talk with your issues with
pagination have there been any issues
with a move on into the mewar even just
theoretical with the URLs getting too
long by requesting so many existing
posts ladies are getting too long yes
yes they well spotted URLs have a set
length and if you put too many IDs in
that then you're gonna have problems
that's why you use a post okay yeah so
use a post for your yeah pagination
Christy yeah thank you sir on that was